you know I was talking to one of the
young man where we're working with and
he reminded me of so many things you
know it was a young man he struggling
with um you know his father passed away
when he was young and it really I think
and he's you know he stood he lives with
his mother still and you know he hasn't
really kind of grown up about 30 now and
I and it just you know and my father
passed away when I was young and so I
could relate I could understand some of
that and maybe reminded me of some of
that and actually you know it really it
taught me about some of the you know
moments that I've never really you know
I'm so oblivious to the world I think
when my pet mom my dad passed away that
I didn't really I wasn't able to really
get a view of how I reacted to it or
what it meant to me or what was going on
or how I behaved or anything but by
talking with this young guy and seeing
what was going on with him I was able to
kind of get a vision of what that what
that can be like sometimes for a young
man and and then I was like oh wow well
I started thinking and this may not be
right but I started thinking and feeling
like oh one of the reasons that you know
possibly one of the reasons that this
young man doesn't want to move out and
doesn't want to grow up is because his
dad is gone it's like it's kinda like we
don't want to if the person who you know
who we care about the most or one of the
peep
we want to see us grow up the most isn't
there then sometimes we just will stop
evolving we'll stop we won't grow up and
it's just it that way it's like [ __ ]
it's like saying [ __ ] you to the world
it's like saying oh you're gonna take my
dad away you're not gonna let the person
that I won't care about the most be here
to see me grow up then [ __ ] you I'm not
growing up and and it's like the only
thing we can do but cuz you know there's
no other way to get back at time or to
get back at the world than by our own
actions really and so we just stay where
we are we say okay time you're gonna
keep going on but I'm gonna stay right
where I am you're not gonna get me I'm
not flowing in your river you know I'm
not flowing forward I'm not evolving you
know cuz the person I want to be here
the most you took them away well I'm
gonna stay right where I [ __ ] am I'll
show you you know this kid that's kind
of invisible I'll show you to the world
to the world that took away your parent
or took away somebody you cared about
but at a certain point you just start to
hurt yourself you know at a certain
point it's like you know you're 30 or
you're getting older and you're still
with at home and and now it's like you
know it's just it's cumbersome on the
young fellas mother and she's getting
older and he needs to be able to
contribute and and I'm not airing his
dirty laundry out there like I'm not
even I'm not ashamed of the guy or I
mean this is just his life this is
what's going on we're all just you know
people that are trying but but yeah at a
certain point he owes it to the adult
him to try and you know to try and get
past it and I understand
young you know him wanting to stay young
forever and stay right where he is and
and nobody else is if you know if he
stays them with his mom there's not
really space for another man to come
into the home and like you know it kind
of like it just hits him just at a core
level that's holding onto everything so
much work you know to what it was like
when he was a kid but he owes it to an
adult him sometimes to move on you know
because then then the adult him as an
experience has a chance to live in the
world and have an experience but it just
it made me think about a lot of things
it made me think about you know how it
made me think about what are ways that
when things happen to me that I would
then like try and connect then try and
control the world so that I could show
the world you know who's boss you know
like oh okay world you're gonna I don't
know I can't think of some kind of but
but I could heavily relate to what this
boy went you know in a way like I could
see like wow sometimes if though if
something happens to us then we hold a
grudge against the world and we can
carry it out in ways that over time
aren't really helpful to us anymore but
it's so wild to see like you know you
see this boy trapped in this man's body
and the the the man's body the adult
wants to move on but there's his boy
just like holding on to like this you
know this grudge honestly against the
world and it's a fair grudge you know
the world took his father but it's it's
an unfair grudge in the sense that
he's not being fair to himself now you
know to the adult him that wants to
really feel free to to challenge the
world and to take on the world and also
maybe don't know what the [ __ ] I'm
talking about good evening good
afternoon and other times thanks for
watching that video you just saw I mean
it was okay but the next video you can
watch could be way better what if you
watch a video right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one watch this one watch
this one watch this one